[Musique]
le chef triplement étoilé Christian
leskerer icône de la haute gastronomie
parisienne s'invite à la Maison
Fournaise de Chatou depuis octobre il
collabore avec la chef actuelle Akima l
berimi il réinvente la carte ensemble je
vous propose qu'on aille découvrir tout
ça
située en bord de seinene la Maison
Fournaise est chargée d'histoire créée
en
1857 les peintres impressionnistes
Pissaro deg ou encore Renoir sont venus
manger ici Auguste Renoir a d'ailleurs
représenter le lieu dans son fameux
tableau le déjeuner des canottiers et
depuis 166 ans l'esprit est resté le
même on y retrouve une impression de
guinguette parisienne et en ce mardi
midi les clients sont nombreux j'aime le
cadre j'aime
l'endroit et puis l'histoire du lieu
aussi c'est important l'environnement
est agréable et puis la cuisine est
délicieuse je viens très régulièrement
dans ce dans ce superbe restaurant et je
je découvre pour la première fois le
nouveau chef et la nouvelle carte et je
suis absolument fasciné par la qualité
des ma la présentation on y vient depuis
très longtemps moi ça fait 30 ans que je
connais cette maison alors je conseille
aux gens qui veulent venir manger des
ravioles elles sont très bonnes
Christian Lesquer est le chef du
restaurant Le 5 au sein du palace
parisien for season George 5 grâce à
cette nouvelle collaboration avec la
chef Hakima elberimi de nouveaux plats
sont à la carte comme le boudin à la
passion ou la mousse au chocolat je
crois qu'aujourd'hui je ce qui est très
bien à mon niveau c'est de d'expliquer
de transmettre un peu on va dire l'art
de vivre dans une petite maison
particulière qui est quand même une
maison bourgeoise entre parenthèses et
se de donner de donner un peu de de P
dans la cuisine les deux chefs mettent
également à l'honneur les produits de
saison et favorisent le circuit court et
le terroir franilien pour la chef Hakima
elberimi cette collaboration est une obè
apprendre le le bonne manière de
travailler la bonne cuisine française ça
fait vraiment un grand grand plaisir de
travailler avec le chef comme chef
Christian
[Musique]
LOSC
bon appétit ma merci c'est l'heure à
présent de déguster pour l'entrée j'ai
suivi les conseils des clients fidèles
et j'ai pris les ravioles de langoustine
en plat le coquelet grillé et en dessert
la surprenante mousse au chocolat tiède
pour un montant total de 64 € la Maison
Fournaise démontre que la haute
gastronomie peut être accessible car le
restaurant propose aussi des menus
allant de 29 à 36 € à la fin du service
c'est aussi l'heure du verdict pour les
clients c'était excellent tout était
excellent vraiment faut pas mettre 20/
20 parce que sinon il y a plus de marge
de progression alors je vais dire entre
18 et 19 sur
[Musique]
20 alors si vous aussi vous voulez
tester le restaurant La Maison Fournaise
sachez qu'il est ouvert tous les jours
sauf le lundi allez bon appétit